helping local businesses governor sissel  act sat down with small business owners  earlier today to discuss nevada's small  business grant program also known as  pets  governor sissel act says nevada small  businesses were some of the hardest hit  during the covet pandemic  and in just four days after launching  the program more than thirteen thousand  applications were received  the state of nevada is not done helping  small businesses  over the next few months we're going to  engage in a series of thoughtful  conversations  with business owners throughout the  state of nevada  through these conversations will be able  to understand the challenges that these  businesses are facing  every single day almost 9 400 small  biz and non-profits able to receive  assistance through that program which  will help them with payroll  rent and necessary utilities